-Welcome back to the program.
-I like the vibe. Nice.
-Yeah. Well, you know,
we're talking about whiskey.
We want to talk about
all this stuff
and all the spirits
and everything you're into.
But I want to talk
about the book.
Congrats on this, by the way.
-Thank you.
-And I also want --
-Is that me on the front?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, yeah, it is. Good, good.
Just checking you got
the right one, yeah.
-Yeah, yeah, it could be me.
I mean, yeah,
we look like twins.
I mean, but...
-We do.
-Did I read this right?
Did you want to be a magician
when you were growing up?
-I probably wanted to be
a lot of things growing up,
yeah, but I think I did give it
a go for a little while,
but I realized
I don't really have the --
I didn't want to put
in the work, you know?
I wanted to put on the outfit,
you know, the sort of the hat
and the cape and the wand
and all that stuff,
but actually
learning the tricks,
I was just rubbish at it.
-So you'd just show up
and go "Aha"
and then "Watch me disappear"
and then leave, yeah.
That was your only trick.
-I could juggle a little bit,
but, I mean, come on, that's --
-That's something.
-That's right.
I mean, I think that's why
I became an actor, right?
So then I can
put on the clothes,
pretend to be someone,
and then not do any of the work.
-Yeah. What was the --
When you were an actor,
obviously,
when you first started out,
you have to take
other jobs to support.
Do you remember
any of those jobs?
-Oh, boy. Where to start?
I delivered sandwiches
by bicycle.
I worked in Harrods.
I sold women's clothing.
-Oh, in Harrods.
-I sold -- Yeah, I know.
Posh, right?
-Yes.
-Yeah, very nice.
I sold perfume and I was
a barman, as well, actually.
In Scotland,
I worked in an Irish bar.
-Wait. An Irish bar in Scotland?
-An Irish bar in Scotland.
I wore a flatcap
and a very dodgy accent.
So, again, yeah -- and I was --
-You pretended to be Irish?
-[ Irish accent ]
Ah, to be sure.
[ Normal voice ] And I poured a
terrible pint of Guinness, so...
-That was your giveaway?
-Yeah, they had me. They had me.
-Yeah. The other week,
I saw you posted a photo of you
just walking around
wearing a kilt in New York City.
-Right. That's not my dog.
-No, it's not your dog.
It's a cute dog, though.
-It is a cute dog.
-Yeah. Do people look
at you differently
when you're wearing a kilt?
-Honestly, in New York,
I think they've seen it all.
They don't care, do they?
-We really don't care.
-I'm going to have to up
my outfit next time.
I'll wear the wizard one.
That's what I'll do.
-Oh, you will?
-Yeah.
-Well, that'll be fun next time
you come on the show.
-Yeah.
-But I saw you're
sticking with the kilts.
Here's you in a kilt
on a glacier.
-That's me in New Zealand,
on a glacier, in commando.
I claim to be the first person
in commando on a glacier.
Thank you very much.
-Wow.
That's your
little piece of history?
-That's it.
-Yeah.
-I went all the way
just to do that, yeah.
-Well, it goes along
to talk about this
in the new book here,
"Clanlands in New Zealand."
-Yeah.
-It's a companion piece
to the show "Men in Kilts."
-That's right.
-You travel to different
countries and you --
In this one,
you explore New Zealand.
-We went to New Zealand,
which is this amazing place.
It's honestly -- It's a bit
like, you know, Neverland,
Peter Pan's Neverland.
There's these islands.
There's alpine.
There's glaciers.
There's fjords. There's jungle.
There's incredible
animal wildlife there.
They've got flightless birds,
great white sharks,
and, of course, you know,
glaciers that I wear
no underwear on.
-Yeah, so smart, yeah.
-Yeah.
-We -- Last time you were
on the show, actually,
we were talking about you have
your own whiskey and tequila.
-I do.
-And they both won awards.
-Thank you.
-Congratulations.
The Jimmy Award, yeah.
-Yeah, I gave you the Jimmy --
You won some
massive, major awards.
And then I had a suggestion
for you last time.
I don't know if you remember
this or not, but the --
-Oh, vaguely, vaguely.
-I'll show a clip.
Can we show a clip of
his last --
-What did you say?
-You go, "Yeah, I'm going
to make a whiskey."
You don't mess around.
-Right.
-You ended up winning
all these awards for it.
And then you made
this amazing tequila.
What is it called?
-It's called the
Sassenach Select El Tequileño,
and we just won a couple of
gold medals for it, as well.
-I mean, dude --
-What's next, right?
-I'm so happy.
-What do you want?
We'll make it.
-Yeah.
I like gin,
if you want to work on a gin.
-Oh, we could do that, yeah.
Jimmy's Gin?
-Ginny Fallon.
Yeah, go for it. You take it.
-You made --
-We made a gin!
-Yeah, you made a gin.
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes.
-And please don't tell me --
did this win an award?
-It's won several gold medals.
-Oh, my God.
-I'm sorry.
-Did it really?
-It really did.
But, obviously,
I wanted to call it Jimmy's Gin,
but I thought
something easier to say,
like Sassenach, right?
-Much easier, yes.
Sassenach, yeah.
-I'm really proud of it.
It's our Wild Scottish Gin.
And, honestly, I'm running
out of things to make,
so next time you invite me on,
I'm gonna have to do --
I don't know -- Like,
what am I going to do next?
-Well, actually, I have
some ingredients here
if you want to make...
-Oh, a cocktail.
-Oh, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now we're talking. Right.
-Why are there --
What do we have here?
Why do we have eggs?
-Eggs are good for protein.
-Well, I understand.
-So, we're going to make you
a Ginny Fallon.
-You are?
-We're going to make you
a Ginny Fallon cocktail.
You're going to help me,
my friend.
-I love this.
-We've got in here --
I've been told, reliably,
that there is --
[ Sniffs ]
Whoo!
Yep, that is alcohol.
-Okay, yeah.
-Gin. Wild Scottish Gin.
♪♪
We've got some lemon juice.
We've got some simple syrup.
-Okay.
-We're going to put
some ice in there.
You're going to put
-Okay, here we go.
-We're gonna make this together.
We're going to give
this a little shake.
-Okay.
-I've already
messed this up, Jimmy.
-You did?
-Yeah.
-Were you not supposed to put --
-It's okay.
-Alright, good.
-It's all going to be fine.
-Why are there eggs here?
-Okay, we got to put
an egg in there now.
-Okay.
-I should have dry-shaken that.
-That's right.
Oh, you dry-shake it.
-Yeah, ever mind.
-Oh, you shake it
without the ice.
-Yeah, right.
-Alright.
Now you can't even open it.
-I can't even open it, Jimmy.
-Wait.
What if we just drink from here?
-Do we need the eggs?
-We don't need the eggs.
-Why don't we just crack an egg.
-Yeah, crack an egg.
-And put it in.
-There you go. An egg in there.
-Now top that in.
-This is fantastic.
Hey, cheers, buddy.
-The Jimmy Fallon.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Not bad. It's actually --
The gin makes it taste good.
Yeah. Sam Heughan, everybody.
Congrats on the gin,
and, of course, the new book,
"Clanlands in New Zealand:
Kiwis, Kilts,
and an Adventure Down Under,"
is available November 7th.
Stick around.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody.